all right Formula One racing in Las
Vegas is a little over a year away but
there is a lot of activity just east of
the Las Vegas Strip that is where our
wrongful Trail is live on this Tuesday
afternoon with the latest Ron
yeah Christian this is where much of the
action will be happening right here for
Formula One November 2023 is when it is
set to take place here you can see some
of the signage already up not a whole
lot to see in this area we're going to
show you what's going on though but it's
we're a couple of blocks east of the
strip near the corner of Harmon and
Koval and this is right where race
headquarters will be located
are we gonna raise that no
that's epic it's gonna be pretty
hardcore event
[Music]
40 acres bought by Formula One for 240
million dollars it was pretty much a
vacant lot but now the Earth is being
moved to prepare for the mid-november
race in 2023. the lot is already decked
out with signs of the race to come by
the way we got Hamilton gets away well
and he's getting towards Maximus down
but now this lot will house permanent
structures the garage or Paddock area
for cars the teams will be set up here
during the race VIP Suites for fans and
team owners will also be on this lot
along with grandstands for the fans oh
no yeah cars are going to enter this lot
from Harmon and exit North on coval
eventually ended up back out on the
Strip where they will head south at
speeds of up to 212 miles an hour
race we have in store for us the lot is
zoned for Casino property so it's
possible the new owners Liberty Media
and formula one could build a hotel
casino on this property the contractors
for three years for this race but
everybody involved feels Formula One is
making this long-term commitment with
the land purchase and the race will be a
fixture in Las Vegas long into the
future imagine what it's going to be
like this is going to be absolutely
Madness
and you're looking live inside there's
some of the caterpillars moving around a
little bit slower I think than the
Formula One cars when they get going in
here in November 2023 this will be the
largest event ever held in Las Vegas not
just sporting event largest ever held in
Las Vegas by the way in Singapore
Formula One Is racing there this weekend
tickets there are ten thousand dollars
for a sweet ticket that's not for the
suite that's just for one ticket in the
suite reporting from just east of the
Las Vegas Strip Ron Futrell eight news
now all right Ron thank you for that and
of course if you're interested you can
register for ticket information at F1
Las Vegas gp.com and we should let you
know that there is a 7.77 cost to
register on that website and ask for the
price of the tickets no forget on how
much that will be but of course he just
gave us a glimpse in dollars for us wow
that is a lot but of course it's going
to be a huge event oh yes yes it will be
but